you mentioned uh avi loeb
i forgot to ask you about omo
you know because you've analyzed
specimens from here on earth what do you
make of that one
and what do you make broadly of our
efforts to look
look at rocks essentially or look at
objects
flying around
in our solar system is that a valuable
pursuit or maybe most of the stories can
be
most of the fascinating things could be
discovered here on earth or on other
nearby planets
just going to omamoa uh
you know i think
avi's insight
is an interesting speculation right
like i was saying before people can
sometimes look at something and not see
it for what it is
many would just look at that and say oh
it's an asteroid and dismiss it
there was something
odd about the data that avi picked up on
and said well here's an alternative
explanation that doesn't fit that
actually better fits the models than it
just being a rock
you know and to his credit
he just has
ignored the critics because he believes
the data is real and is using that then
as a battering ram
to go after other things so i think
that's i think that's great
you know yeah
what what is his main conclus does he
say it could be of uh alien
extraterrestrial origin is that well
that's one of the things i mean he you
know he's explained how it could be a
light sail
um
and a light sail is certainly within
near human capabilities to make such a
thing i think
yuri milner is he's a russian
billionaire
he's involved i think in a project to
make light sales with laser
you know to to
launch them with laser power essentially
uh towards alpha centauri
right so it's something that
humans
could make
i think avi's proposal is perfectly
within the realm of possibility i mean
sadly the thing is you know now nearly
out of our solar system yes i mean to me
that's inspiring to
do greater levels of data collection
yeah in our solar system but also here
on earth it just seems like we should be
constantly collecting collecting data
because the tools of software that we're
developing get better and better at
dealing with huge amounts of data it's
changing the nature of science i mean
collect all of the data right collect
the data i mean i i um the galileo
project asked me over the weekend to
join and i did
so um you know i'm not a specialist in
any of the stuff that they're doing
uh but you know in looking at the list
of people who are on there there are
really no biologists on there so at at
some point if my expertise is required
for something what's the goal in the
vision of the galileo project better
talk to avi but my understanding and
just actually looking at the
at the sort of the bylaws this morning
literally just got them
um is uh number one collect the data on
uap and number two collect data on uh
local
potentially
local technological artifacts i need to
look into this this is fascinating and
the avi is heading the galileo project
yeah have you spoken to him
on this podcast yes that was be i
believe is before he was headed it was a
new creation yeah the galileo project
was i think it's about six or seven
months old now okay you know amazing and
he's getting a group of scientists
together oh yeah about 100 oh it's it's
actually i am
i was looking at some of their stuff
over the weekend i'm shocked at the
level of organization that they've
already got put together that's amazing
it looks like
a moonshot project i mean i've been
involved with a lot of nih large nih
projects
which involve a lot of people in
coordination and
they're putting it together
you